if i asked you to close your eyes and
imagine some wildlife you'd probably
conjure up an image similar to this
or even this the focus of your
visualization
was most likely the cute little fox
rather than the digitalis plant
or the conium maculatum plant well
you're not alone in this a 2016 study
showed that study participants remember
images of animals better than they
remember images of plants
[Music]
we've never been at this point of
disconnection and estrangement from the
natural world before
we're surrounded by synthetic and
electronic entertainment
and we don't interact with plants and
nature as we once would have
had we been growing our own food or
hunting for our own food
and this has resulted in what is known
as the
nature deficit disorder where people
don't recognize plants at all
other than something that they may
consume for dinner
[Music]
the human eye sees green a lot easier
than any other color
so it tends to grip green objects
together
and and fade them into the background
and then there's the evolutionary
development within humans that early
humans were threatened by animals
we also had to look out for movement for
a fast-moving lion coming to eat us
therefore the human eye picks up
movement and looks
for movement so we often don't recognize
plants which are relatively unmoving
[Music]
connecting with nature affects us from
our heads to our toes
from micro bacteria in the soil which
studies show it can enhance well-being
to petrichor the smell of the earth
after it's rained
to the sound of birdsong which has been
found to decrease the stress hormone
cortisol i realized i was
disconnected from the natural world
about eight years ago
during a period of recovery from
depression
and addiction issues i found myself
drawn to walking
daily on walthamstow marshes and the
experience of
of being in nature and walking on the
marshes became
as important and as therapeutic as
the medication the psychotherapy and the
support of friends and family
[Music]
those who have less access to outdoor
space
and two and a half million people in
britain don't live with an
easy 10 minute walking distance of a
green space
have fewer opportunities to decrease
their stress
through contact and connection with the
natural world
[Music]
so every year more plant species go
extinct than animal species
and in fact cites which is the
convention on international trade
in endangered wild species that's fauna
and flora
has thirty thousand plant species listed
compared to the
000 animal species which are in danger
of extinction
from legal and illegal trade plants and
fungi
are the foundation on which humans and
animals really depend
and yet they're not recognized and they
are the underdogs they just keep toiling
away
and keeping us alive you don't need
anything to go out in nature
you just need to find something that
you're interested or curious in
i love insects and lychen and moss
so i'm always looking around for the
different species
i can find and patterns and shapes so
i'd say just
find something that makes you feel
wonder and awe
and say wow and just just continue your
lines of curiosity plants are essential
to
to us they're not just a green
background or something for us
or animals to eat they are significant
in our survival as a species and as a
planet
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bell to receive
notifications for new videos
see you again soon